could I have cleaned my entire house
in the time it took me to do this
one bathroom?
yes yes I could’ve
and I feel like her and I might have a fair bit in common
because she might look clean on the surface
but once you get to know her
you'll find out she's fkn filthy
so this is the only bathroom we have in our house
and it services my family of five
we have other toilets thankfully
so that when my husband runs off for three hours at a time
I can actually access this one. anyway
between the five of us and our endless
rotation of house guests over summer
this bathroom has taken an absolute beating
the first step was to strip out the shower
and then spray it within an inch of its life with mould killer
and I let that marinate while I cracked on with this drawer
and I really got no one to blame for this mess but myself
in my defence
end of last year was hectic
I had an event or two to go to pretty much every single day
plus we're renovating
and we were hosting Christmas and New Years and house guests
and I just haven't had a minute
but it's January and I'm back on my shit again
and I've decided that I'm getting my
entire house deep cleaned
decluttered and organised before
well before I lose the motivation I guess
and please don't judge the state of my
brushes or my sponges okay
I'm already judging me
enough for the both of us
I think I did five rounds of little baths for them
and then when I was happy
I set them out until the sun to dry
when I got on with organising the rest of my makeup
I like to organise my makeup by categories
if you know what I mean
so I got a section for eyes and brows
a section for lips
a section for face
a section for my palettes
that sort of thing
and then on the other side
I wanted to try and actually make some
space for the rest of my family
so I've got all of our hair stuff in one basket
and then our oral hygiene stuff in the other basket
Side note
but I'm trying to manifest two more bathrooms in this house
by the end of the year this year
tall order I know
but I need to put a bathroom in downstairs for my sons
and I need to put an ensuite in
you know, for me
and then I imagine my daughter and my
husband will share this bathroom until
she gets old enough and kicks him out too
and so yes I will admit
this bathroom is absolutely overflowing with product
but just remember
no actually I can't even say there’s
5 of us sharing it
cause this is all my shit
I like skincare
okay arrest me
I organised all my face stuff into brands
and then on this side
I've got hair and body care
and then once the section of the bathroom was organised
it was time to get cracking on the deep clean
and honestly
this is my favourite part
I do like organising
but I just like cleaning better
but honestly
organising this bathroom is such a punish
cause it's so tiny
so what you didn't see was me off camera
sitting in the hallway with three kids and a dog
going through each and every one of my products
trying to decide what to keep and what was expired
and where was my husband throughout all of this
I hear you asking
he was at golf
not even a word of a lie
but I was happy for him
he doesn't golf often
I think it's important for him to go out and
have guy time, whatever. plus
this is my happy place
and if he was here trying to help me
I'd be pissed off by now
telling him to get the fk out
I decided to try the TikTok baking soda and vinegar
Hack down the drain
don't know if it was doing anything
but it felt like it was doing something
and then I just steamed everything as much as I possibly could
honestly that steamer is my favourite gadget
it was the best purchase of 2023
you would have heard me say it before
my only regret is that I didn't get all of my cleaning appliances sooner
honestly if my children ever decide to get married
not to each other
obviously, to other people
I'm gonna get them all new cleaning
appliances as their wedding presents
I just feel like a new family needs to start off with new cleaning appliances
then you can take care of them and hopefully keep them for years and years
my dad's always known how much I love to clean
I take after my mum
in that respect
and so when I got married
he decided to get me a washing machine
yeah it was second hand
I think it cost him 50 bucks
and we had to go pick it up ourselves
not to sound ungrateful
but I really didn't wanted to clean my
wedding present before I got to use it
you know what I mean
don't come at me that
he was probably hard up against it
or he just paid for our wedding
cause neither of those are applicable
anyway love my dad
probably would have loved him more if he
got me a brand new washing machine 🤭
12 years later
and she's still obviously still a bit salty about it
Nah, it's just funny now
sorry about the rant dad. anyway
we're on the homestretch now
and it's time to clean out the final cupboard
and i won’t lie
I saved this one til last
because I seriously considered just not doing it
but I wanted to do it because I
wanted to give my husband a little space
and by ‘a little space’
I mean he now has two shelves 😇
look at me being all generous & shit
but seriously
last time I did this
I had a bunch of comments from
people telling me that it didn't leave my husband enough room
okay firstly
he has like 3 products
he doesn't need a bunch of space secondly
he knows he's welcome to share anything in this bathroom
and he uses the skincare
behind the mirror too
And thirdly I don't know what it is about guys
or maybe it's just my guy
but he looks really good with wrinkles
so can you blame me for gatekeeping some
of my anti ageing shit
wow okay we've really covered some ground in this one
and I apologise
but I also can't help but spin a yarn
Ok. I'm officially over it now
my feet are aching
my back is aching
my mouth is aching from all of this shit talk
and even though I didn't fill up my drawers with teeny
tiny mouthwashes and teeny
tiny toothpicks and teeny
tiny other shit that I probably don't need
look it’s a realistic reset I guess
but it does kinda make me wonder…